[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eric ciotti député des alpes-maritimes
elle est l'invitée de l'épreuve de
vérité bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de public sénat des
échos de radio classique et de la fp
avec moi ce soir pour vous interroger au
rial mancini et paul briat bonsoir à
tous deux eric ciotti trois grandes
questions pour vous ce soir un la
fermeté face aux migrants est ce
désormais l' axe principal de votre
parti il axe prioritaire de l air
deuxième question votre parti est il en
train de succomber à l'anti libéralisme
puisqu'on a noté ces derniers temps
certaines prises de position notamment
sur le smic
troisième question est-ce que vous
reconnaissez tout de même qu emmanuel
macron est le premier président qui ne
recule pas sur les réformes
d'ailleurs pour cela notamment il séduit
votre électorat mais d'abord une toute
première question d'actualité bien sur
l'évasion spectaculaire de redoine faïd
le braqueur récidiviste qui interroge
sur les défaillances de sécurité pour la
ministre nicole belloubet qui le répète
depuis ce matin il y a peut-être eu des
défaillances peut-être pour vous c'est
certain c'est certain l'évasion d'un
détenu comme on dit particulièrement
signalé c'est le terme juridique mais au
profil extrêmement lourd braqueur
multirécidiviste impliquée dans ce
braquage qui je le rappelle a causé la
mort d'aurélie fouquet cette jeune
policière municipale
ce n'est pas un acte banal ce n'est pas
un fait banal il y as forcément une
défaillance par rapport à la dangerosité
au profil coutumier des évasions de ce
personnage tristement connue je crois
que les précautions n'ont pas été prises
en tout cas cette halle enquête
administrative
même à une enquête va être engagée dès
aujourd'hui vous vous contenterez de
cette enquête de la nuit nous avons
demandé c'est guillaume larrivé monk
l'aig député de l'yonne et membre de la
commission des lois qui a demandé
l'audition de la garde des sceaux devant
la commission des lois à tout le moins
nous attendons des explications sur les
défaillances qui ont conduit à ce fiasco
c'est surtout que selon le journal
l'opinion les gardiens avaient fait part
de leur doute sur une possible évasion
de redoine faïd il avait informé
l'administration centrale via une note
il y a dix jours est ce que pour vous la
défaillance est politique en tout cas il
y à une défaillance à trouver les avez
les évasions il y en a toujours eu donc
à une quinzaine peut-être par an il y en
a malheureusement toujours eu ce qui est
grave
j'ai en effet l'administration
pénitentiaire à pointer ce risque et
avait demandé
compte tenu de l'inadaptation de la
prison de réau au profil de dangerosité
de ce détenu
son transfert vers un autre
établissement plus et mieux sécurisé
mais pas la bonne prison il n'aurait pas
dû trop ce que disent les
les gardiens qui avait sollicité son
tranfert les responsables de la
pénitentiaire qui ont sollicité se
transformer au delà au delà du duché qui
est choquant parce que encore une fois
moi je pense à aurélie fouquet derrière
je pense à tous ces drames qui sont
associées au parcours de ce criminel qui
a été condamné à la réclusion criminelle
de façon très très lourdes il y a
aujourd'hui la situation de
l'administration pénitentiaire de nos
prisons qui se trouve dans une situation
extrêmement grave qui manque de moyens
il y a un déficit de places de prison il
ya une surpopulation carcérale séparés
où on vous revenez autour de 70 mille
détenus en france il y à 58000 place il
ya une surpopulation carcérale c'est
bien d'une action mélange des profils
très lourd avec des profils plus plus
léger donc il faut revoir la politique
pénitentiaire en france
il faut plus de moyens il ya une
question de moyens vous savez j'ai
rédigé un rapport sur l'exécution des
peines à la demande nicolas sarkozy
cette étape 2011
c'était des pistes que j'évoquais la
spécialisation des établissements et
puis surtout
plus de places de prison café madame b
loubet qu'a fait le gouvernement qu'a
fait le président de la république je
vous rappelle que pendant sa campagne il
promettait 15000 places de prison
supplémentaires en cinq ans cette
échéance a été reportée en dix ans on a
perdu une année on attend la loi de
programmation judiciaire elle est
annoncée à l'automne mais ça veut dire
que 18 mois auront été perdus alors que
sous le précédent quinquennat
madame taubira s'était opposé à la
création de places supplémentaires
monsieur revoit ce opportunément avait
changé un peu la donne à la fin mais
c'était naturellement trop tard alors
vous rappeler la mort de cette policière
municipale effectivement lors d'un
braquage raté
néanmoins cette évasion spectaculaire je
le disais suscite peut-être une certaine
fascination auprès de certains est ce
que ça ça vous inquiète
on rappelle que ce bandit était aussi
une figure médiatique
j'ai vu des commentaires de deux
maîtrises dalle pour pas la citer que je
ne sais pas si on doit lui faire de la
publicité qui années chez aller dans une
forme d'éloge de de ce parcours et de
cette évasion c'est extrêmement choquant
je suis extrêmement choquant parce
qu'ils peuvent être fasciné par cette
évasion est derrière par le parcours de
la personne qui s'est évadé parce que
dans ce parcours il y a il y à des
drames et il ya notamment ce ce drame
que nous rappelions et j'ai une pensée à
cet instant pour toutes
pour aurélie fouquet pour sa famille et
bien sûr pour tous les policiers tous
les gendarmes qui on le dit jamais ce
trop souvent sont victimes en permanence
de cette violence du quotidien la suite
de l'épreuve de vérité avec la question
que va vous poser maintenant au riad
mancini
[Musique]
eric ciotti est ce que la fermeté face
aux migrants celle axes prioritaires des
républicains il faut la fermeté parce
que la fermeté sera gage d'humanité
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui il y
a eu treize mille morts en méditerranée
depuis 2015 il y a eu 6000 morts dans
l'année qui a suivi l'appel de madame
merkel à l'ouverture des frontières ce
message qui a été très lourd de
conséquences et je le dis qu'il fut une
erreur tragique en disant en gros on
peut vous accueillir
on va y arriver cette phrase venez en
europe
il y a eu au cours depuis 2015 1 million
600 mille migrants qui sont arrivés en
europe et il ya eu ce cortège de drames
ce cimetière en méditerranée et vous
arrivez deyres les arrivées sur les
côtes méditerranéennes elle baisse
depuis deux ans ils baissent
drastiquement mais les morts beaucoup
moins 900 morts depuis le début de
l'année en méditerranée et certains
disent la crise migratoire n'existe pas
c'est j'ai entendu monsieur macron c'est
une irresponsabilité totale certains
disent effectivement même alain duhamel
avis il n'y a pas de submersion
migratoire mais en revanche il ya une
submersion populiste oui ça c'est nier
le problème savez c c'est comme quand
monsieur jospin disait et il n'ya pas
d'insécurité il ya un sentiment
d'insécurité
aujourd'hui qui peut nier que le défi
migratoire que l'on a connue est encore
de façon beaucoup plus grands accentué
devant nous je vous renvoie au livre de
stephen smith
on ne peut pas le qualifié de populiste
il a été journaliste à libération au
monde cet universitaire aux états unis
de la poussée de la frime c'est
démographique en afrique ces deux
milliards et demi d'habitants en 2050 on
est un milliard deux cent cinquante
aujourd'hui l'afrique c'était au début
du siècle une 750 millions de solutions
si on verrouille et il parle de 4
milliards d'habitants à l'horizon 2100
c'est à dire 40 % de la population de la
planète donc il va y avoir cette poussée
migratoire
ça veut dire qu'il faut changer de
politique et naturellement il faut plus
de fermeté il faut continuer à
accueillir
les vrais réfugiés politiques mais
aujourd'hui dans ces flux ils sont
extrêmement minoritaires parce que c'est
l'honneur de l'europe c'est l'honneur de
la france est notre histoire
c'est notre tradition d'accueillir ceux
qui sont opprimés dans leur pays
notamment pour des raisons politiques
mais parallèlement je les dirai en même
temps on ne peut pas accueillir
aujourd'hui des migrants économiques
pourquoi parce que nous n'avons plus la
capacité and europe et bien sûr en
france de les intégrer
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les jeux d'hier
et les les capacités de s'intégrer que
ça soit professionnellement que ce soit
au niveau de la connaissance de notre
langue et donc au niveau culturel mans
on me le dire aussi vous pouvez vous
penser aussi à la religion non je ne
pense pas à la religion je pense à la
capacité d'animation
quand on arrive dans un pays que nani
logements connaît qu'on ne maîtrise pas
la langue qu'on n'a pas de capacité
professionnelle qui sont avérées pasqua
on a des regroupements ethic ethnic
pardon et donc on a le développement du
communautarisme et le communautarisme on
l'a vu c'est le terreau du terrorisme
est alors au rythme islamistes disons
les choses très clairement aujourd'hui
alors vous dites c'est l'honneur de
l'europe doit d'accueillir les vrais
réfugiés mais certains disent
aujourd'hui que c'est le déshonneur de
l'europe on va écouter
ian brossât qu'est le chef de file
communiste pour le lait les européennes
et il nous interpelle directement
bonjour monsieur ciotti il est devenu
coutumier depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines de taper sur ces associations
qui viennent au secours des migrants en
méditerranée j'ai entendu les propos du
président de la république qui
expliquait que ces organisations non
gouvernementales notamment sos
méditerranée serait complice des
passeurs ces propos sont insultants ils
sont d'ailleurs similaire à ceux que
vous avez tenus et à ce que madame le
pen a tenu quelques semaines plus tôt en
réalité ces associations qui viennent
tout secours des migrants font un
travail admirable et elles font le
travail que les états de l'union
européenne sont incapables de faire pour
secourir ces hommes ces femmes et ces
enfants
est-ce que ce que vous êtes en train de
nous expliqué monsieur ciotti c'est
qu'il aurait fallu laisser ces gens se
noyer en mer on est dans la caricature
on est dans la caricature sur cette
question sur les ong
oui je le dis aujourd'hui les ong se
font directement ou indirectement et je
ne nie pas qu'il y a dans ces
organisations et des personnes qui sont
animés par un sentiment de générosité
qui qui est à souligner mais
structurellement ces organisations se
font les complices de la des passeurs il
constitue à bien des égards le dernier
maillon de la chaîne des passeurs
aujourd'hui une enquête a été ouverte
j'ai vu par le procureur de catane il y
a des liens directs entre les passeurs
et ses organisations
il y a des bateaux qui vont récupérer
les migrants dans des eaux territoriales
libyennes
donc là où monsieur brossât et peut-être
sur ce point je peux le rejoindre dit
les ong sauvent des vies parce que les
états ne le font pas je le dis très
clairement c'est tout ce sont aux états
sont aux états d'accomplir cette mission
et tags et graffs et bien messieurs
savinykh ministre de l'intérieur italien
par exemple par des d'italie tout de
suite il a grâce à vos yeux ce
l'intérieur américain mérite selon vous
d'abord je veux dire que pour moi ce set
à l'europe et aux états d'avoir cette
mission un de bloquer le départ des
bateaux des côtes libyennes et
tunisiennes et ça je souhaite une action
d'une flotte européenne y compris
militarisé sous mandat de l'onu qui
puisse intervenir dans les eaux
territoriales libyennes sous mandat de
l'onu à la fois pour empêcher le départ
des bateaux parce que si on empêche pas
le départ des bateaux les migrants vont
arriver en europe et il n'en repartiront
plus il faut dire la vérité très
clairement et en même temps de sauver
les vies mais ce n'est pas à des
organisations qui quelque part qui
quelque part directement où je le redis
indirectement nourrissent le commerce
des passeurs en amidon voulait nous dire
que va nous dire que vous avez vu ça
c'est aussi fini est ce qu'il a un don
cameron
c'était la question illiards d'euros 5
milliards 7 je crois c'est le chiffre
d'affaires de ces négriers des temps
modernes
mais s'il l'a dit l'union européenne
l'italie problème à bras le corps la
semaine dernière c'est un bon accord est
ce que c'est une vraie avancée pour vous
je réponds à l'ordre questions sur
matteo salvini sur l'italie d'abord
l'italie
je verrai publiant applaudissent des
formidables italie l'italie a voté et
moi je n'insulte pas le résultat des
élections vous parliez tout à l'heure de
populiste laurent wauquiez a cité cette
phrase d'hubert védrine en dix ans le
populisme c'est l'échec des élites et il
y à quelque paradoxe assez de la part de
ces évite de critiquer les raisons
finalement qui ont nourri le populisme
parce qu'elles en sont la cause
prévisions sont aujourd'hui parle
monsieur salvini monsieur comptes ont
été élus l'italie est une démocratie il
y a eu des élections et je le dis sur le
fond je vais pas me dérober
oui l'action qui a été prise a fait
bouger les lignes
et je pense qu'elle est de nature à
apporter une nouvelle réponse la réponse
française
la réponse allemande nous a conduit à la
faillite des politiques migratoires
l'angélisme de monsieur hollande de
madame merkel
poursuivi par monsieur marc chrome parce
que absolument rien n'a changé a conduit
à cette crise donc il faut changer de
politique et le gouvernement italien
avec sa prise de position avec le
blocage des ports je crois je le dis a
fait oeuvre utile pour qu'on change de
politique donc vous nous dites qu'un
ministre de l'extrême droite en italie a
fait bouger positivement les choses
l'extrême droite c'est vous qui dites
ans maintenant sinon je crois que vous
le classer ou alors c'est pas comme ça
qu'ils se qu'il se classe en tout cas la
ligue du nord elles dépassent très
largement quand même les racines que
vous évoquez c'est un gouvernement qui a
été lu il ya le mouvement 5 étoiles qui
part à rattacher ont valu au fascisme
avec c'est un gouvernement de coalition
donc bien sûr je sais qu'il est de mode
dans le politiquement correct de
dénoncer ces formes de gouvernement de
populisme mais en tout cas vous savez à
mépriser le peuple un moment le choeur
le peuple se révolte et il est en colère
moi je ne méprise pas le peuple et le
peuple
il a un bon sens le bon sens de dire
aujourd'hui les politiques migratoires
et nous conduisent elles ont connu un
échec majeur il y a des morts en
méditerranée
et ça personne ne peut le dire vous
pouvez pas le nier et si monsieur
salvini fait reculer les mort en
méditerranée
eh bien il aura fait oeuvre utile mais
c'est pas céder alors notre sondage
opinionway rien ne posera sa question
tout de suite après première question
pour 50 % des français la france devrait
accueillir moins de migrants
pas plus pas moins 35% et il se trouve
13% des français d'après sondages qui
disent on doit accueillir plus de
migrants vous y voyez une confirmation
de votre position ferme
oui je le crois mais c'est ce que
j'entends au quotidien sur dans le
département où je suis élue qui est
confrontée aux chocs migratoires dans le
département dans le département vous
êtes élu les et maintient le nombre de
migrants ont refusé aux frontières
carabine 10 2 42%
le nombre de migrants refusé aux
frontières a bondi de 42% selon un
rapport de la cimade
les choses ont plutôt dans le bon sens
en tout cas de l'enfance de votre
politique pour l'instant il y a eu un
effet un contrôle aux frontières depuis
le 13 novembre pourquoi il ya ces
blocages depuis le 13 novembre 2015 nuit
tragique du bataclan le contrôle aux
frontières a été rétablie par dérogation
au traité de schengen est aujourd'hui la
frontière est contrôlé par trois
compagnies républicaines de sécurité par
deux unités de gendarmes mobiles par par
des militaires également et il y a eu
cinquante mille interpellations l'année
dernière et qui ont été des personnes
qui ont été reprises par les autorités
italiennes et je le dis d'ailleurs au
gouvernement aujourd'hui il faudrait
peut-être évité de trop insulter les
italiennes parce que ils ont une clé
majeure parce que si demain il ré ouvre
la frontière
ça veut dire que les 500 mille étrangers
en situation irrégulière dont parlait
monsieur selvini pourrait se retrouver
sur nos territoires donc soyons prudents
dans les coups de menton prononcent à
leur art monsieur macron vous avez parlé
de monsieur salvini je vais vous
interroger sur deux personnages de
sebastian kurz d'abord puisque c'est
l'autriche aujourd'hui qui prend la
présidence alors la présidence à lui
alors il est extrême droite vous êtes
d'accord ça vous chagrine ou pas il il a
été il a été élu il a été élu il ya des
institutions européennes encore une fois
ils respectent ces institutions nous
nous verrons bien comment ils
s'accordent pas l'autre personnage qu'on
ne connaît pas c'est l'ambassadeur de
france en hongrie en est qui a loué la
politique de viktor orban qui est
évidemment très décriée mais
c'est ambassadeur de france à lui alloué
sa politique migratoire il a dit que
c'était une un modèle à suivre
il a carrément fermé les frontières on
le rappelle urban est ce que cela
appelle selon vous une sanction vous
prononcer une phrase des dix ans je
rappelle aux rebelles un ferme et
l'effroi ben oui c'est donc ça vous
paraît vous choquer ça peut paraître
assez contraire c'est pour bien au
contraire
absolument pas assez là vous faites une
erreur et vous tomberez dans le
politiquement la hongrie c'est la
frontières extérieures de l'europe et on
dit depuis des mois dans tous les
discours y compris dans ceux de monsieur
macron dans les conclusions du sommet
européen
il faut protéger nos frontières externes
donc ce que je sais pour tanger
l'ambassadeur de france a dit la vérité
monsieur ban à protéger les frontières
externes de l'europe et vous le vouer
aux gémonies
je suis choqué par la révocation de
l'ambassadeur de france en hongrie
il a fait de notre sincère si tu devais
partir mi juillet c'est une révocation
cave mais que je marque on l'a dit et il
l'a fait je suis choquée parce que c'est
une note interne si désormais les
ambassadeurs dans les notes internes qui
sont quelquefois chiffrés qui sont
codées ceux qui sont transmises au quai
d'orsay
si on ne peut plus dire la réalité sio
né dans le politiquement correct par
tous nos services diplomatiques seront
considérablement affaibli décrire une
réalité dire que monsieur urban a été
élu deux fois deux fois avec une très
large
la suivre écoutez c'est une analyse
manger je n'ai pas vu cette cette note
met au monde un jugement politique et
morale sur la note d'un fonctionnaire
c'est vraiment grave y'a un délit
d'opinion désormais dans la fonction
publique si on ne pense pas comme la
pensée officielle
eh bien on peut être révoqué ce pouvoir
et c'est une nouvelle dérive de ce
pouvoir qui est de plus en plus il
marque de plus en plus une forme de non
pas d'autorité mais d'autorité d'accord
alors toute dernière question sur la
perspective des européennes à l heure et
on change de sujet républicains ont tenu
ce week end dernier avant ton gars
conseil national à paris europe 1 je
crois sur les européennes est ce que
jean leonetti serait par exemple une
bonne tête de liste maintenant qu'il est
numéro deux du parti et sam européen est
ce que c'est un choix qui vous
satisferait puisque ce sont non comment
sa série très largement décidera de
celui ou celle qui conduit rang conduira
notre liste avec ceux qui feront partie
de la liste un peu plus tard jean
leonetti est quelqu'un de très très
grande qualité il a été ministre des
affaires européennes il est élu des
alpes maritimes comme moi je connais ses
qualités il a beaucoup de qualités ça
pourrait arriver que les pour être à 100
de ceux qui pensent qu'on sent surtout
qui pourrait prétendre à conduire cette
liste
ah ben oui oui vous ne vous mouiller pas
plus à ce que le choix n'est pas fait
aujourd'hui nous en déciderons avec
laurent wauquiez à l'automne je préside
la commission nationale d'investiture
nous nous verrons bien en tout cas vous
avez raison de décrire un excellent
aller la suite maintenant la question va
vous être posée par paulo brillant
[Musique]
eric ciotti est ce que les républicains
sont en train de succomber à l'anti
libéralisme pour contrer à la fois
emmanuel macron marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon c'est l'impression qu'on peut
avoir après certaines prises de position
de ténors des républicains qui notamment
après une hausse massive du smic c'est
pas trés trés la droite française telle
qu'on l'a connue ce sens nous nous
faisons un constat aujourd'hui de deux
problèmes majeurs dans notre pays
d'abord le niveau extrêmement élevé de
nos prélèvements obligatoires qui reste
parmi les pays de l' ocde
parmi les plus élevés on est à 46 % de
taux de prélèvements obligatoires il
prélèvements obligatoires ont augmenté
et deuxième problème qui finalement
année tout simplement la cause c'est le
niveau extrêmement élevé des dépenses
publiques
nous voulons redonner du pouvoir d'achat
aux français c'est clair soit par une
baisse d'impôts et moi je le souhaite
personnellement je le dis savez vous que
j'ai eu un bâtirons notre projet mais je
souhaite que les républicains soit le
parti de la baisse des impôts et de
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
le débat est ouvert doit pas y avoir de
questions dabou tabou j'ai entendu
guillaume pelletier j'ai entendu valérie
pécresse propose proposé cela il y avait
6 il ya aussi là aussi la porte ya aussi
la question de la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires qui avait donné
du pouvoir d'achat s'est dégradé pour
dominer l'idée de nicolas sarkozy elle a
été refusée à l'assemblée nationale
quand nous l'avons proposé nous avons
déposé dans la position vieux routier
parce que nous avons déposés sur la
profession est ce que vous êtes
favorable moi je ne joue bien je pense
que ce débat mérite qu'ils soient posées
voilà ces pannes c'est pas débat tabou
j'ai pas aujourd'hui de une position
c'est pas la position que je privilégie
pour redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français
moi je pense qu'il faut faire baisser
massivement les impôts notamment l'impôt
sur le revenu qui pèsent sur une partie
très réduite des français avec des taux
de plus en plus élevés je pense à l'acf
et qui a pesé de façon très injuste sur
les sur les retraités donc pour moi la
priorité c'est d'abord la baisse de la
fiscalité la baisse de la fiscalité
redonnera du pouvoir d'achat et puis
troisième mesure la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires aussi parce que
alors on avait vu l'impact que ça avait
il ya eu pour 9 millions de fermer en
2020 c'est bien aussi engagé on verra
s'il ya eu une baisse de la fiscalité
mais que toucher simplement une partie
des françaises que vous dites vous aussi
en macro c'est le président des riches
c'est c'est une évidence c'est une
évidence quand l'on regarde les chiffres
l'insee l'a rappelé quatre milliards et
demi de hausse des prélèvements
obligatoires pour les ménages en 2017
coeur 2010 8,4 milliards en 2018 quatre
milliards et demi de hausse pour les
ménages auxquels qui s'ajoutent aux 50
milliards du gouvernement hollande macro
rappelons quand même que monsieur
m'apprend était le ministre de
l'économie de monsieur hollande donc j'y
vois une prolongation des lignes et ceux
qui ont bénéficié
finalement deux dispositions fiscales
plus favorables
ce sont ce lien n'est fait on un
patrimoine même pas les grandes fortunes
à l'intérieur des grandes fortunes les
actifs financiers l'immobilier restent
taxés très lourdement
on a l'impression qu'il ya des vaches à
lait pour ce gouvernement les retraités
les propriétaires donc oui on concentre
les aides pour les détenteurs d'actifs
financiers à un très haut niveau
notre sondage opinionway la suite la
deuxième question eric ciotti portait
sur l'image de lr aujourd'hui les
français se divisent en fait si on
regarde sur l'ensemble des français la
moitié pensent que l es rassemble des
personnalités de droite uniquement et la
moitié voit également quand même encore
parmi vous des personnalités du centre
les républicaine notre famille politique
reste en effet eu une alliance un
rassemblement je préfère rassemblement
d'ailleurs de personnes qui viennent
d'horizons
différents avec des racines communes les
gaullistes les libéraux les centristes
donc bien sûr et on parlait de jean
leonetti toute la diversité de mela il y
à des centristes compte les tendances
joie qui compte dans les tendances ont
plus souvent d'en accepter valérie
pécresse a été une nouvelle fois ci fait
ce week-end on a entendu quelques
signaux à bout jeudi la cire et que
c'est vous cautionnez pas trop désolé
pour aujourd'hui vous vous vous
attendiez c'est sifflé ou les aviez
annoncé aux jeudis vous excusez moi je
personnalise pas le propos mais
sincèrement valérie pécresse a été très
bien accueilli elle elle est intervenue
avec une voix qui est importante qui
compte est là elle a fait des
propositions qui ont été applaudis il y
a eu un petit mouvement
quand elle est arrivée mais mais très
marginal c'est peut-être quatre cinq
personnes dans une salle où il y avait
mille personnes et vous ne vous dites à
peine à christian estrosi quatre ans
après achevé république doit lui
contrairement à valérie pécresse n'est
pas venu s'exprimer
il l'a pas et j'aurais aimé qu'ils
s'expriment devant les républicains je
sais pas si si c'est toujours sa famille
politique mais j'aurais aimé et que
christian estrosi viennent et c'est ce
que lui ont dit les militants aussi
viennent prendre la parole lors de ce
conseil national en expliquant pourquoi
il considérait qu'il fallait voter la
loi sur l'immigration
pourquoi il considérait que monsieur
collomb avait été le meilleur ministre
de l'intérieur de la vème république
donc mieux en mieux que nicolas sarkozy
pourquoi les mesures sur les
collectivités locales sont tellement
bonne voilà moi j'entends christian
estrosi je le respecte je respecte
toutes les positions
enfin vous ne voyez plus comme un
bourrin mais il indique d'ailleurs il
est dans un soutien permanent au
gouvernement ce qu'il avait voulu
demander la rive ses traditionnels
moi je lui dis simplement cantonné dans
un soutien permanent au gouvernement eh
bien il faut en tirer naturellement les
conséquences on peut d'ors et donc
quitté les verts est dedans mais ça
c'est à lui de d'avoir cette attitude
moi ce que je regrette est ce que ce que
ce que lui disent les militants parce
que c'est pas nouveau
ils lui disent clary
et clarifie votre ou ta position vous
vous étiez président de la commission
d'investiture de l air est ce que
christian estrosi pourra pourrait être
investi les républicains pour la
municipale à nice
dans deux ans nous verte nous verrons
bien mais aujourd'hui ce serait plutôt
non je dirais que c'est à lui de
clarifier
c'est à lui de clarifier sa position un
peu plus dur mais on va pas personnalisé
sur trois dit il ya plusieurs versions
concernées
arnaud robinet jean luc moudenc
christian estrosi qui fait partie de la
liste qui envisage un rapprochement ou
en tout cas un rapprochement avec des
élus se disent parfaitement compatibles
dans tous les cas avec le factuel et
edwards avoir des macros ni sur leur
liste est ce que je faisais mère l'a
oubliée
aucune alliance n'est possible avec en
marche
donc il aurait séjourné à quelqu'un et
la position que je défendrai si en
marche donne son investiture à monsieur
estrosi ou à d'autres il ne peut pas
prétendre à l'investiture des
républicains après des maires ont
toujours composer leur liste avec des
personnalités différentes mais qu'il y
ait une alliance institutionnels comme
monsieur castaner avait tendance à le
souhaiter avec certains maires ça ce
n'est pas possible la vie politique
exige de la clarté
on a des valeurs qui sont différentes de
celles dans marche on le voit au
quotidien notamment sur les questions de
sécurité de protection des français de
lutte contre le communautarisme au plan
économique ont évoqué les impôts il ya
d'énormes différences donc si un moment
on nous dit vous êtes tous pareils ça va
bénéfices alors qu' aux extrêmes c'est
ce que veut monsieur macron qu'il y ait
une espèce de conglomérats centrale et
de l'autre côté face à lui plus que
madame le pen et monsieur mélenchon eh
bien nous ne ferons pas ce cadeau d'un
monsieur mac ronde le laisser dans
l'antre soit avec monsieur mélenchon et
madame le pen
nous avons une responsabilité c'est de
proposer l'alternance
il n'y a que les républicains qui
pourront battre monsieur macron en 2022
pour cela soyons très clairs sur nos
positionnements pas de confusion encore
moins de compromission naturellement
avec avec le valeur savez la vie
politique exige de la clarté
et bien moi je tiens cette ligue alors
soyons clairs alors imaginons
effectivement christian estrosi
présente évidemment à la noue un nouveau
mandat à nice il n'obtient pas
l'investiture des républicains peut-être
qu'il l'a réclamera pas d'ailleurs mais
alors ça y est la voie est toute tracée
pour vous eric ciott et vous vous
présenter à la mairie de nice est ce que
c'est ce que vous aviez annoncé ce
week-end de près de 13 ministres et
menton vous organiser un meeting je
n'attendais pas ce week end à levens ou
alors nous serons trois mille 3000 avant
jc le rassemblement de seulement dans
les alpes-maritimes me soutiennent je
suis niçois je suis viscéralement
attaché à ma ville il y a aujourd'hui
des difficultés dans ces ya des choses
qui vont bien dans cette ville et mais
il y a des difficultés notamment une
énorme inquiétude financière avec une
situation très dégradée qui a fait
rentrer la métropole dans le réseau
d'alerté des finances publiques en 2017
et qui a conduit aujourd'hui à une
augmentation massive des 1 mondial
devient relou eu deux milliards de
dosettes entre la métropole et la ville
de nice est considérable
2 milliards d'euros de dettes ça veut
dire que c'est la collectivité après
paris la plus endettée de france il y a
à la fois la dette et les impôts donc ça
fait partie des oppositions des
différences en tout cas très forte que
j'ai qui porte une autre candidature de
mme au delà du positionnement politique
que nous évoque lui pour justifier votre
candidature de main de la question se
posera l'année prochaine bon alors on
voudrait pas aujourd'hui est posée
jamais d'alliance avec en marche mais on
sait que certains poussent en coulisses
au sein de votre parti beaucoup à
l'extérieur aussi pour des alliances
avec l'extrême droite par exemple ce
matin sur public sénat c'est un nicolas
dupont aignan qui reviennent tenait ces
propos
je suis convaincu que si on veut battre
macron et changer de cap il faut
réunifier la droite il faut réunifier
les patriotes les républicains ça se
fera de toute façon n'en déplaise les
lots des grands chefs ça sera ça se fera
dit il certains disent que c'est le plan
caché de laurent wauquiez
sûrement pas pas d'alliance avec en
marche les ti mais naturellement aucune
alliance avec le front national
bien entendu bien entendu nous l'avons
tous
pour répéter je leur la sentais la
pression de la base dans les
alpes-maritimes celle et je crois
militants et leur ça serait une erreur
elle est bien là la base ça serait une
erreur fondamentale et qui ne ferait que
servir la continuité de monsieur macron
et sa réélection nous avons des idées
nous avons une famille politique
une histoire des valeurs qui n'ont rien
à voir avec avec l'extrême droite
donc nous ce que nous disons c'est que
nous n'avons aucun tabou a abordé des
sujets notamment ceux de la sécurité de
la lutte contre l'islamisme de
l'immigration parce que le front
national ne peut être le seul à évoquer
avec souvent une forme de caricature ces
sujets il faut que nous répondions aux
attentes des français
il faut que nous fassions revenir vers
nous des électeurs qui viennent de chez
nous qui nous ont quittés parce qu'ils
étaient déçus et quelquefois ils ont eu
raison et qui sont allés vers le front
national mais il faut que ces électeurs
et je le redis il sache très bien que
tant qu'il y aura cette situation avec
un front national très élevé ça ne fera
le jeu que de monsieur macron c'est à
nous de porter l'espérance de
l'alternance troisième partie de
l'émission monsieur ciotti et ses
organes à nouveau qui va vous poser la
question
[Musique]
est-ce que vous reconnaissez quel manuel
maquereau et le premier président qui ne
recule pas sur les réformes réforme qui
d'ailleurs séduit ce votre électorat
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup d'illusions
dans dans la communication qui est
nourri par monsieur macron là dessus il
y à quelques réformes qui ont été faites
mais elles sont beaux et je les ai voté
j'ai voté la réforme du code du travail
j'ai voté la réforme de la sncf mais si
on regarde bien au delà de la
communication qui est survendu par le
pouvoir
quelle est la réalité les chefs
d'entreprise s'en rende compte
d'ailleurs sur la réforme du code du
travail il y a une forme de déception un
an après et ils nous disent bon mais
finalement ça pas tant changé que ça ça
reste très compliquée c'est allé
beaucoup on n'a pas touché par exemple
au temps de travail aux 35 heures ça ça
aurait été la mère des réformes sur la
sncf
est-ce qu'on a touché aux régimes
spéciaux des retraites non on n'y a pas
touchés donc bien sûr il ya l'affichage
qui semble décrire un président qui
réforme tout mais faisons le bilan un an
après elle est l'audace est pas moins le
mérite de tenir face à la rue qu'elle
ait l'audace calé lequel et le courage
est-ce qu'on a modifié le temps de
travail est ce qu'on à modifier l'âge de
la retraite est ce qu on a baissé la
dépense publique non la dépense publique
a fortement augmenté
cet éternel m'en vanter la réforme de la
sncf est allé au bout malgré les
tentatives de blocage de syndicats
jusqu'au boutiste bien sûr qu'il fallait
tenir
il n'y avait pas le y avait pas le choix
mais je veux je veux vraiment nuancer
cette idée qu'il y à une réforme